[Musique]
coupure nette à l'oreille c'est pas le
fait d'un renard enlever un noeud ils
sont touchés tout ce qu'il ya autour
mais vraiment l'enlever c'est pas un
corbeau le vétérinaire est monté il a
regardé madiba c'est une mutilation
je veille sur mes cheveux toute la nuit
je prends ma ronde incertaine heures et
jusqu'au matin
après c'est ma voisine qui prend le
relais depuis le mois d'août
la psychose s'est installée chez les
propriétaires de chevaux du jura on
compte déjà une vingtaine de signalement
dans le département
tanguy bourgeois fait partie de ces
propriétaires mortifié par ce qu'ils ont
découvert un après midi il retrouve sa
jument couché dans les orties totalement
amorphe n'était plus indécents sur les
jambes arrière elle bavay de l bavay et
puis bah voilà l'été a été shooté la
jument son urine c'était comme de la
lessive dans les sitcoms du liquide
vaisselle ou une lessive en fait ça
certains pas bon et pour moi c'est un
truc chimiques
ce jour là une autre agression à
caractère sexuel
adieu à quelques kilomètres sur une
autre jument même signature dans le
sordide
un éleveur il cherche à voir ces bêtes
vivent bien pour massacrer ses souhaits
l'autre jour quand on a retrouvé ce
jugement la semader à dire fallu tigres
soit côté leurs fans le même sort le
même un détail a attiré l'attention des
deux agriculteurs la trace d'une piqûre
sur l'encolure l'agresseur connaît
forcément les chevaux jamais je me
permettrai d'endormir une bête par
intraveineuse font des années des années
d'expérience puis des études quoi il est
peut-être pas vétérinaire à son cabinet
havre un cabinet d'avoir eu des cours de
formation des formations
les chevaux ont ils été anesthésiés
sédaté avant leur supplice de l'ue tour
au trot bertrand franquet et vétérinaire
il soigne les chevaux de l'équipe de
france de saut d'obstacles pour lui on
ne mutile pas un cheval sans le droguées
auparavant et quelques blessures que
j'ai pu observer au sein de ma clientèle
c'était des vrais des sureaux type
lacérations avec bistouri du trajet de
la juguler c'est ce qu'ils font des
traitements médicamenteux un des
produits soient tranquillisants soit un
anesthésiant pour pouvoir faire ces
maltraitances
après il ya toujours le le problème de
deus fournissent il s'est produit
donc c'est sûr qu'il va y avoir une soie
d'une complicité soit une malversation
auprès de certains confrères cookies
sont fait voler en quelques mois les
gendarmes ont enregistré plus de 300
signalements en france mais tous ne
correspondrait pas à une attaque humaine
loin de là certains propriétaires
pourraient surinterpréter les blessures
chaque fai fait l'objet d'une enquête
pour déterminer les causes des blessures
sur les équidés et si on regarde ce qui
se passe sur le plan national on
aujourd'hui dans 25% des cas seulement
les interventions humaines
autrement dit beaucoup d'animaux se
blesserait eux mêmes sur les barbelés en
tentant de sortir des pâtures une
version qui passe mal dans le milieu
équestre comme chez ce couple qui dort
dans les écuries depuis trois semaines
depuis l'agression au scalpel de leurs
juments singla surnaturel mais aller et
faire une belle offre et coupé l'anus
sur 17 cm 5 5 mètres de profond à
découper de la commencer la sarthe
descendez la jusque-là lvt venir nous a
bien expliqué que parlante dans les
abattoirs et coupet à cet endroit là
pour les vider beaucoup de propriétaires
sont à cran eux sont prêts pour
l'autodéfense
on a mis dix caméras oui des armes
légales sont vendus dans le commerce
avec des cartouches en caoutchouc
dans ce contexte la gendarmerie
multiplient les patrouilles pour éviter
que les propriétaires ne cède à la
colère pourquoi ils font ça quoi bah ce
que tout le monde se pose pourquoi ils
font du mal aux chevaux gratuitement à
ce jour aucun suspect n'a été arrêté